Ahmed
of the APC
having satisfied the requirements of the
law
is hereby declared the winner
and is returned elected
[Applause]
jubilant supporters of the governing
party celebrate victory in Hartford and
tense election
their candidate 70 year old Bola Ahmed
tinubu now has the task of trying to
calm a divided country
I take this opportunity
to my fellow contestants
to let us team up together
it is the only nation we have
the unfortunate his Declaration was
boycotted by the main opposition
political party Representatives who
accused the Electoral Commission of
colluding to rig the vote
the opposition has strongly criticized
the Electoral commission for failing to
electronically upload election results
right from polling units this they say
was a deliberate attempt to rig the vote
election officials however have told
them to take their case to court
something the opposition isn't entirely
happy with Judiciary is said to be the
last hope of the Common Man it is so in
all other matters but in political
matters
sorry to say the Judiciary is not the
last hope of the common man I hope and
pray that the Judiciary will live up to
their responsibility of being The Last
Hope of the Common Man
this election has deeply divided
Nigeria's
we have no other country than Nigeria
all we need to do is to carry every
those of you that are grieved don't just
fight don't protest if you have anything
to protect go to court this bar cannot
be our leader it's not our mandate
will have to work to unite a fractured
country in addition to dealing with its
numerous Economic Security and social
crisis
for now the streets of the capital and
many other parts of Nigeria are calm the
next few days will determine whether
they stay that way Ahmad Idris Al
Jazeera Abuja
well let's get more on this we're joined
by bolandle olukani she is an Nigerian
TV host and documentary filmmaker and
she's joining us live from Lagos very
good to have you with us on Al Jazeera
you have been saying that this election
wasn't free or Fair tell us what you're
basing that on
so you know when we're talking about
what a free and fair election is a free
and fair election pretty much means that
people have the right and access to vote
they're able to vote on Saturday what we
saw was a lot of people were
disenfranchised from people
um inec the body that was conducting the
elections they were disorganized they
were not up to par with the logistics of
actually conducting the elections so
this meant that for some polling units
inec didn't arrive there until afternoon
a lot of people came out to vote so
imagine in some polling units you have
over a thousand people and inec was not
able to allow all those people to vote
so that's just one example when you say
it was not a free and fair election
because people were disenfranchised so
the national electoral commission or
inec has you're calling it they have
been monitored by International
observers from the Commonwealth and the
Commonwealth have listed some
deficiencies including what you're
saying of
um of election officials of materials
showing up late among many other issues
but they are saying the international
observers that these do not amount to an
election being not free not fair and
that the whole process has not been
marred at all what do you say to that
I say first of all we're not going to
judge and base whether or not an
election is free or Fair because the
international observers said so the
international observers they have their
own reason for saying that because they
don't want to undermine the Nigerian
election we the Nigerian people with all
the evidence that was out there the
violence the disenfranchisement the fact
that inec did not show up on time the
fact that inec's still up to now has not
uploaded the results at least 50 percent
of the results one to the portal the
fact that we saw places where people
actually changed the results canceled it
out and these results are not tallying
with the results that people collected
and took pictures of because a lot of
Nigerians took pictures of the final
results so the International Community
they're more than welcome use to make
the decision that they have by saying it
was free and fair but we the Nigerian
citizens a lot of us do not agree that
it was free and fair and there's
evidence to prove that the violence the
fact that people were chased away from
their polling units we have videos of
people thugs coming to steal ballots
with police escorts and nothing has done
nobody has been arrested how can we call
that a free and fair election it's not
possible there have also been a lot of
videos circulating on social media in
Nigeria that fact Checkers including at
the BBC's disinformation team have said
uh not from this election at all from
years ago do you think that there is or
do you acknowledge or believe the BBC
and others fact-checking reports that
there is a lot of misinformation on
social media surrounding surrounding
this election
I am a huge I absolutely hate fake news
I work in the media and I know how
dangerous fake news is a lot of the
things that I saw I made sure I fact
checked them not only that I know and
have people who were at polling units
and they actually show videos where they
came and they scattered the ballot boxes
it was when that military came that they
were able to go ahead and vote but there
were other polling units like for
example in emo states where the inec
never showed up inec didn't show up but
yet they uploaded results how does inec
explain that to us so do those people
were they ever able to vote that's what
we're seeing when we're saying this
there was no communication for inec all
these questions we had I next sent one
press release that one press release
said we understand that there were
issues but you know we're gonna have to
go ahead and continue to correlate the
results and after that anybody that has
any issues you know they can take it up
with the quote a lot of people were
disenfranchised from voting the numbers
are not telling and we're asking for
inec to respond to the issues that were
that we've raised the International
Community yes the International
Community as much as we appreciate their
support we're not going to use what they
say to verify whether or not our
election was free and fair
we thank you for your time joining us
live from Lagos there
thank you
[Music]